10 years of youtube
we've pursued our dreams of making films
but now
we're taking it to the next level we are
launching digital.com
brand new website that gives you the
best viewing experience
of all of our videos and it allows us to
make brand new projects
with your support outside of the youtube
and hollywood systems if you subscribe
to the website not only you get all the
videos
ad free but you get access to new
exclusive shows and
a brand new green light feature that
allows you to put your subscription
dollars
towards the projects you want to see you
want to know it just got greenlit while
the site was in beta heck yeah
the vlogs back by popular demand and
that's just the beginning
there's more perks you get access to
exclusive live streams early access on
all videos
site-wide discounts on merchandise and
we have ios and android apps if you want
to watch these videos on your phone
or chromecast them to your tv oh wait
lately before we go any further
nothing will be changing about our
youtube channels and the content that we
make on there but on corridordigital.com
you're going to be getting way way way
more due to the power of your
subscription
all right pause the video right there
okay what do you mean by that well
youtube heavily devalues you as a viewer
to us on average your view is only worth
one tenth
of one cent so if we want to make a
single dollar on youtube a
thousand people need to watch one of our
videos so what that means is that a
single subscription for a month on
quarterdigital.com
has the same influence and power as 4
000 people
just watching on youtube that's crazy
but ren can you put that into
perspective for us
let me show you this is what 4 000
people would look like
however if you are a quarterdigital.com
subscriber you would have the power to
carry them all so as a subscriber what
can you do with that power well that's
where the green light feature comes in
each month your subscription dollars are
converted to producer points
which you can use to pledge towards the
project you want to see
we asked everyone if they wanted the
vlogs back and guess what they did they
pledged right away we got them back
they're live on corridordigital.com
right now go check them out the vlogs
aren't the only new show we have from a
master class inspired series on
filmmaking to a brand new tactical
reload series
chances are there's something on there
that you've been dying to see so head on
over to coldweardigital.com and check
out what new shows are ready for you to
greenlight
we are really excited about this model
because it's something special
it's making content for you and you only
not for some algorithm not for some
search engine ad empire and definitely
not for some executive that thinks they
know what you want to see yeah i think
we can all see a gap that's forming in
the content that we watch today
i mean who knows what the future of
movie theaters are and youtube is great
but definitely lacks for many so for
other artists
and ourselves creating our own platform
is the future of filmmaking we also want
to take a moment and say a special thank
you to all of our patrons who have
supported us on patreon
you guys have selflessly helped us out
through all these years and we're going
to give you something in return
all qualifying patrons are given a free
subscription to their website
as of this month so thank you if you
want to take control over what you watch
head on over to corridordigital.com and
grab yourself a subscription
you will get all videos ad free
and in higher quality than youtube it's
hd access to exclusive shows
like the vlogs powered green light shows
with your subscription dollars 15
off of all merch exclusive livestreams
with the entire crew
and a general sense of well-being all
for just 3.99 a month
there we go we finally set the price ran
would you put that into perspective for
us
sure thing you see that's just 13 cents
per day and 13 pennies would be this big
a little more impact please rent more
impact okay fine if the penny was the
size of the earth
13 earth-sized pennies wouldn't even
make it to the moon
perfect that's so cheap corridor
digital.com
wow
[Laughter]
quarterdigital.com
there you go